in today's video we'll be using spline
spline is an easy to use 3D design tool
geared for any designer regardless of
their 3D experience what makes this 3D
design app so special is that you can
use it on a web
in today's video we'll be rotating an
object a seesaw object and making an
animation out of it so if you actually
click right here and hover over the
object it rotates
hope you guys enjoyed the video
all right the first thing you want to do
is set a plane so let's rotate this to
90 degrees upward
and let's scale this out
but we got our sofa plane let's set its
color to
in nicer's like mustardish orange
there you go I like that
let's make it a little bit bigger
so that will be our plane that we'll be
working on uh now let's go into
perspective zoom in a little bit so you
know we can perspective and see what
we're actually making we're making a
seesaw object I'll be animating it so
when you hover over the object it uh
there's a little animation
so first let's click the 3D cube button
and make a cube on top of our plane boom
now we got our Cube let's start shaping
it so I want to make it kind of like a
triangular base so to do that you want
to actually click on smooth and edit
and if your Cube becomes this make sure
you just turn the level the subdivision
modifier level to zero and then let's
take this plane
and just
reshape it so if you take this button
just push it down you can make it
yourself a triangle
and now after we're done with that you
can actually click off
and
kind of scroll this down now you see
that this is kind of too sharp of a
triangle so I'm going to actually edit
the mesh
um go back
and I don't want a super triangle I just
want like something like that right and
then let's just bring this down a little
bit so looks like a nice solid base
you know
all right
uh now let's set our base color to
a nice bluish color not bad and then
let's get the cube and actually start
working on the top part of it
so
let's do something like that
slower this
and what I like to do is
kind of go like that and then align it
just
kind of line like that all right so now
you just want to extend it
and click kind of Click shift so you
know like it's kind of
are on the same width length
um it's kind of too thick so I'm gonna
pan it down
looks about even line it up that should
be good
yeah that should be good all right and
let's make this um the same color as
this so you can just copy paste
the color index boom
it's pretty nice
all right now next uh we can do a little
thing the kids sit on
um just a simple
little object oops
boom
slow it out
all right I kind of like that and we're
gonna make this a nice
kind of red
and let's duplicate this
and actually send it over here
just aligning it real quick so it looks
about perfect
now not you've made your kind of like
seesaw object uh we're gonna start
animating it so I actually want to make
this plane even more bigger
and let's go into isometric real quick
so this is kind of be the camera we're
going to be using to play with it
um
and raise the light a little bit
rotate the light
like that just rotate with the light
play around with it see if you like it
all right we're gonna we're just gonna
go with this that's fine
um
so
to get this whole thing working and
animating we're going to use events so
if you click off an object or click onto
object singular object or group uh
there's things that says States and
events so states are different object
states that you can maneuver from so
it's like a plan or sorry not a plan a
spot a to spot B
so to get this whole thing moving I
think I'm going to just group it so
select all of this Ctrl G
and this too so oops
I'm gonna get all
gonna get all of this into a group
so boom we got a group
and we're gonna just select this whole
group so this is our whole grouping
right here
and we're going to create a state so
this is our base State
um
since
we don't want the
this to you know animate with this this
little Cube we're not going to actually
put that in the group so we're going to
just keep all of this just
the top part so let's create a state the
base state
um so the thing with this to make a
smooth animation are base state so our
neutral state has to be already tilted
uh axis so
if it's tilt it like that
that should be good and our state all
right second where we want to get to
should be
kind of counter of that so if our base
State rotation is 19 this should be
around like a negative 19 but we're just
going to keep it like that so it goes
from that to that
and then so how do we get from base
state to state into a smooth animation
that you can interact with
uh when we finish we create an event
and we're going to call this event a
hover over event
sorry I'm going to be hover over with
our Mouse
this event happens or this action
happens so make a transition and then
from current state and what I do from
base state to state so it goes from that
position to that position from this
position to that position
and then the transition we can choose
between ease and out is out spring is
linear we're going to go with ease out
it's the most smoothest one in my
opinion
and then after you've chosen all of that
if we actually go back
to here I
and then
click on this on base day
when we click play and we hover over it
it actually goes down and it's a little
interactive thing you could do
and you can kind of like mess with it
not go all the way and just keep it
neutral
and it's kind of cool
uh you could play around with this more
and add more features and get more
complex with it
um
you can change the
the action from Mouse over to like a key
uh whenever you're looking at it gain
control that logic
um
or you can change the transition so if
you do like a spring
it goes very fast
as you can see
and yeah you can mess with this um you
can create more transitions more
rotations more cool things and yeah this
is just a simple spline tutorial hope
you guys enjoyed it and see in the next
one